hello everyone and welcome to two very
exciting games from rounds uh seven and
eight of this year's cter Masters we
have two games by American Grandmaster
64 year-old Gregory kaidanov um
obviously the best age to play chess and
we're going to show his game against
Jordan Pest and then in round eight his
game against Magnus Carlson he faced
Jordan with white and Magnus Carlson
with the black pieces now the first time
I heard about Gregory kaido was uh very
very long time ago in Josh wkins grandm
series uh although already mentioned
this a couple of times on the channel
Josh weskin was I believe only a part of
the grandmas edition of Chess Master
that's like Edition 10 and uh he has his
Academy there and uh he annotates one of
his own games I believe from 1995
against Gregory kaidanov where he won uh
and if you guys can get your hands on
the that Academy like particularly the
Josh W wein Academy from the Chessmaster
grandmas Edition series uh it will do
wonders for for your chess because I
know you have so so many ways of
learning chess nowadays but the the way
Josh whin explains chess is just on a on
a level i' I myself have not seen to
this day uh so uh that being said uh
let's check out the game and I just
wanted to mention where was the first
time that I heard of Gregory kaidanov um
he's also member of the American uh
Chess Hall of Fame since 2013 I believe
and uh well obviously very long time in
chess and a very strong player so let's
check it out uh here he opened with Pawn
to D4 sorry uh my bad uh here he opens
with Pawn to D4 yeah this is a game
against um uh yordan we have Knight to
F6 by Jordan Pawn to C4 C6 and now
Knight to C3 we have Pawn to D5 E3 and
pawn to E6 going for the semi slav
defense The Accelerated move order
variation Knight F3 Bishop to E7 and
Bishop to D3 now and well there are a
couple of ways you could handle this for
example castles and Knight be to D7 are
top moves now days Jordan goes for DC
captures and C4 sort of the the main way
to tackle this in the olden days
something that I believe Gregory would
be more more fond of uh because it tries
to take advantage of the fact that you
just played with the bishop and now
black forces you to waste another Tempo
and then even another Tempo so okay
Bishop captures Pawn to B5 Bishop back
to D3 and now Pawn to B4 a very forcing
variation if you will Knight E4 and now
uh Knight B to D7 and um uh there are a
couple of moves that were played here
but Knight B to D7 is a new move so
already as of move nine we have a
completely new game uh we have Knight
captures on F6 uh Knight captures on F6
and now Pawn to E4 Gregory grabs the
full Center here Bishop to B7 and now he
castles we have Castles by ordan and now
Pawn to E5 and now this already should
make black a little bit uncomfortable as
you've opened up this diagonal you've
given away the E5 square like I would
not play this with black I would be
terrified of playing this with black
because I would know what I want to do
here with white uh so Knight to D7 and
now Bishop to E4 stopping C5 as the
bishop on B7 is undefended and now uh
Jordan needs to figure out away on how
to play this now the safe way to play
this is something like Knight to B6 to
D5 or you could maybe even Lounge
forward with Pawn to F5 right away or
you could start with Rook to C8 uh but
Jordan plays something different he
plays Queen to B6 and here uh Gregory
asks him a very unpleasant question he
plays Bishop to G5 now I've um allowed
the engine to Crunch the numbers here
because I of course am always interested
in the objective truth aside from you
know uh showcasing the the interesting
parts of the game and the engine says
okay Queen back to d8 the queen does not
belong on B6 but no Grandmaster will
admit that kind of a that Queen to B6
was a mistake and uh you know take back
a move and um of course Jordan will not
do it as as well uh he plays Bishop
captures on G5 and he accepts The
Challenge and now of course you know
what you would play here if it's a
bullet game it's if it's a Blitz game
even if it's a classical game you will
play this and so does Gregory he plays
Bishop captures on H7 as all the all the
known um uh you know tactic points are
here so King captures and Knight
captures on G5 with check now of course
you cannot go back if you go back with
the king queen H5 and that's it you just
get checkmated even if you uh leave some
room for your king doesn't matter just
Queen captures an F7 with check King h8
and now Rook 8 to D1 threatening Rook D3
followed by Rook to H3 Checkmate and if
you stop Rook to D3 by Queen B5 just
simply Rook E3 and now the other Rook is
coming to Checkmate the king uh there's
no move that even postpones Checkmate
it's uh you're just getting checkmated
here so by going into this Jordan
already said okay my king is coming to
G6 and now Queen to G4 now there are two
ways of exploiting this and if you've
ever analyzed such you know also known
as the the Greek gift um sacrifice uh
you know that Queen to G4 is one way to
do it Queen to D3 is the other way to do
it sometimes Pawn to F for his move that
has to be played because there are uh
you know uh little differences in
Black's moves that you have to take into
consideration now here both Queen to D3
and queen to G4 are fine I can just show
you like Queen to D3 check F5 and now
you go for Knight captures on E6 and now
okay Rook eight A8 you will gladly give
up material because white already s
sacrifice material Queen to G3 check
King F7 and now Knight to G5 check King
E7 and now Knight H7 going for Queen to
G5 check which of course will prevent
the king from escaping via the d8 square
so King to d8 you give back a little bit
of material but now E6 and here black
will uh have to resign uh as after Rook
captures on E6 now you play Knight
captures on f8 and after Knight captures
Queen captures and G7 black position is
completely busted he does have a knight
and Bishop for a rook but the bishop is
not even in the game you will simply
trade off a pair of Rooks and then it's
a king and a queen and Rook against the
the bear King on the eight uh of course
a very easy to handle but okay that's a
lot of move so Gregory goes for Queen to
G4 it's also a well-known maneuver uh
Pawn to F5 and now Queen to G3 taking
away all of the important squares from
the black king and there's just not much
you can do here if you try King to H6
then just Queen to H4 with cheick and
after you go here Queen to H7 check you
sacrifice the Knight F4 check King G4
and now Queen to H3 will be Checkmate so
uh you can't uh try something like that
so after Queen G3 uh you could try uh
maybe escaping with the King right away
uh doesn't work but you could maybe try
Pawn to C5 this seems to be working it
guards the E6 pawn and after d captures
you will play Queen C6 just to put
pressure on White's King but still
Knight captures an E6 opens up a
discovery from the queen and after King
F7 Knight to D4 attacks the queen E6 is
coming with check and you're winning
back material you've completely busted
open the black kings defenses that's it
so after Queen G3 Jordan tries Queen
captur and D4 but now just Knight to E4
with check King to H7 and now Queen to
H4 check now you cannot go back as um
okay if if you go back Knight to F6
check picks up the Queen the queen on D4
is undefended so he goes forward King to
G6 and now Queen to G5 check King F7 and
Rook a to D1 connecting nicely with the
queen and the Knight on the dile queen
captures on E5 other moves don't really
help if if you try to give back some
material uh it doesn't work because
after it captures and F captures the
Knight is again hanging and you just get
checkmated wherever you go doesn't
really matter so after Rook a to D1
Queen captures and E5 was played by
Ordon but now just Rook captures on D7
with check King G8 and now to top it off
top it all off Rook captures on B7 as
the knight uh here on e4 is so to say
Immortal you cannot capture it with the
pawn as the queen hangs and if you
capture with the queen then Checkmate
will uh happen on G7 so Queen captures
on B2 it's uh I mean it's one of the uh
least tasty pawns I believe Jordan ever
captured but you know what are you going
to do and now Knight to C5 introducing
the final attacker into the game we have
Rook to F7 blocking the Checkmate on on
G7 but now just The Rook captures on F7
King captures and another Rook comes
into the attack we have queen to queen
to E5 and now Rook to D7 with check King
to G8 or you go here and then you get
checkmated on E7 so King to G8 and now
Pawn to H4 getting rid of any and all
back rank issues so now you don't have
to worry about it and um there's really
nothing you can try here Rook to E8 was
played uh but now Queen to G6 and he was
in this position on move 31 that Jordan
F forz resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh if you
try Queen to E1 check you can okay throw
in a few more checks let's say queen E5
check but now even King to H3 is fine
but okay you can play G3 doesn't matter
and after some F4 moves you will play G4
and even you can give one more check
there are simply no way to reach the
white king to maybe go for some sort of
a perpetual and after you play some
moves because there really aren't any
good ones Knight to E4 and once Knight
G5 lands that's pretty much it for
example A4 Knight G5 and queen H7 will
be
Checkmate uh of course Queen H7 Queen to
h8 will be Checkmate as The Rook covers
this there's no way to you know even
even try anything here uh so this is the
game Gregory versus Jordan varez from
round seven of this year's cutter
Masters and now uh as Gregory won this
game very nicely he gets to play against
Magnus Carlson in round eight and now we
are going to check out this game uh let
me just load it up here so this is
Magnus versus Gregory kaidanov let's see
how Gregory now tackles the highest
rated player in the world with the black
pieces so Magnus opens with D4 Gregory
goes for D5 we have Bishop to F4 Magnus
goes for the now nowadays called The
Accelerated London system you know as if
the the London can get even more
accelerated but okay Pawn to C5 Pawn to
E3 and Knight to C6 Gregory tackling
this in a sort of a traditional fashion
uh C3 and now Knight to F6 we have
Knight to D2 by Magnus and now uh you
could probably develop the bishop and
then close the structure but Gregory
decides to close the structure right
away and he will tackle the development
of the light Square Bishop later on
which again is a sort of um nowadays
modern Grand Masters will try this and
then they even they don't care if they
have to trade the bishop for a knight
but this sort of a
um a less modern approach to to the
opening Knight G2 F3 C captures on D4 he
trades once on D4 and now goes for
Knight H5 he wants the eliminated
magnus's Bishop Bishop to E3 and now
Bishop to D6 uh taking care of D F4
Square so next you know that Knight to
F4 is coming Magnus goes Bishop to D3
and now Knight Knight to F4 forcing
Magnus to give up the dark Square Bishop
uh the only other option as the bishop
and G2 are attacked is to bring the
bishop back to F1 which of course you
don't do so Bishop captures Bishop
captures Gregory wins the bishop pair
here castles and now uh castles as well
we have Rook to E1 Bishop to D7 and the
position has been reached before even in
some top tier games for example G3 was
played in a game Alexander PR played it
against sorry Sergey kakin played it
against Alexander PR but lost that game
and also vidit had this position against
Leon Aran vid played Knight to E5 and he
won that game but Magnus goes for Knight
to B3 and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game and as
you'll see the Knight will be quite
useful on B3 so Pawn to B6 of course you
don't want the Knight to come to C5 so
Pawn to B6 we have Queen to E2 uh and
now Pawn to G6 now making the the the
bishop on D3 not so useful a piece we
have Pawn to a for now uh and pawn to F6
Gregory not afraid of Magnus he says E5
is coming but Magnus says not so fast
Bishop to B5 and this is a very standard
way of um handling the the pressure in
the center now E5 would be a bit
premature because you simply eliminate
the defender of E5 for example Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now you
tackle the other defender of the E5
square or the pawn on E5 and after the
bishop moves you will simply play D
captures on E5 and even if the pawn gets
spinned it doesn't matter Knight B D4
attacks the undefended bishop here and
once you defend the bishop now you
advance the pawn to uh all the way to E6
it's a defended pass Pawn of course this
is objectively now winning for white so
okay after Bishop to B5 Gregor is very
nicely done Magnus he plays Queen to C7
now put some pressure on the H2 pawn and
pawn to E Pawn to A5 the Knight on B3
nicely supports this advancement we have
Rook a to E8 uh D6 Pawn is a little bit
weak it's a backwards Pawn so uh The
Rook definitely belongs on E8 and Now
Pawn to G3 not only kicking away the
bishop but also taking care of the sort
of the potential weakness on H2 if the
knight ever mooves so Bishop back to H6
and now a captures a captures and pawn
to C4 very nicely done uh D captures we
have Queen captures and C4 now also
putting pressure on this diagonal here
and queen to D6 uh and now okay you
might have some ideas of trading of
Queens with Queen to D5 but Magnus say
not so fast Rook to A6 goes after the
defended Pawn on B6 uh Rook to B8
defending it and now Magnus finds a
beautiful way of continuing this um uh
sort of uh well early ons sloth with
Knight to C5 and it's a very very tricky
move uh point is that after B captures
you will play D captures and attack the
queen on D6 and uh the queen has to
defend the Knight here as the Knight
here is attacked uh you will have to
move to C7 to defend the Knight and now
you just capture Bishop captures Bishop
captures and queen captures on E6 goes
after after the bishop on C6 and you
will get something like this for example
Queen F7 Rook captures a bishop here and
after Rook captures on B2 you will play
Rook to C7 force a queen trade here for
example captures captures and you end
this with Magnus being up a pawn and
it's a beautiful past C Pawn so again uh
objectively you should win this so after
Knight C5 Knight captures on D4 Gregory
finds the correct continuation Knight
captures on D4 and now Queen captures on
C5 so now you cannot capture the bishop
as the queen here with hang uh Rook to
A7 putting pressure on the bishop on D7
and now uh how do you how do you deal
with this it's a very tricky position
point is that uh if you play Bishop
captures on B5 then the idea is Queen
captures on E6 check and after the king
moves Knight captures on B5 and you
cannot capture the Knight if you capture
the Knight of course then you cannot
prevent Checkmate Queen E7 and you're
getting checkmated but even if you don't
uh capture the Knight how are you
stopping the the queen from controlling
the seven Rank and checkmating the black
king uh you might have an idea okay
let's play Rook B T8 this kind of gets
the job done but no Here Comes Queen
captures on E8 and after Rook captures
Queen captures how are you defending
Checkmate you have to block with the
bishop and now Rook to C7 trying to
forcefully give or or you know force
feed the black queen the the Knight on
B5 but if you capture then Rook captures
and f8 will be Checkmate so you have to
keep control of this diagonal but now
comes Rook to F7 and there no defense
you can block you can defend with the
King but simply trading off Rooks will
do Rook captures and f8 queen captures
Rook captures King captures and now
you're up a full Knight of course
completely winning so after Rook to A7
Gregory plays Rook B to d8 again uh a
very nice move and also the the
strongest one and now there are a couple
of moves that Magnus could play like
Queen captures on C5 or he could play
Rook to C7 but Magnus knows chess and he
plays Pawn to B4 and how to tackle this
well now seems like a good idea to trade
off Queens Gregory play Queen captures
and C4 Bishop captures and now Gregory
plays Rook F to E8 and this is uh sort
of it's hard to call this move a mistake
because uh maybe you can still hold it
but there there was a better way to
handle this and that is to play Pawn to
B5 and once Pawn to B5 is played idea is
that if Bishop captures on E6 now and of
course this Fork happens you will simply
uh skew the Knight and now the Rook on
E1 is undefended and after Knight
captures Rook captures with check you
get this position Rook E4 attacks the
pawn and this is uh easily easily drawn
uh or if you after uh for example B5 you
don't go after the pawn you try to keep
the tension doesn't matter just King h8
you unpin and now if you don't want to
see E5 you have to capture on E6 and
it's basically the same variation you
will just capture here and that's pretty
much it uh not not much here even even
the bishop can be activated now with
Bishop to D2 so this is a very important
move however he played Rook F to E8
defended the pawn and now sort of is
threatening this but now Magnus plays
Pawn to B5 and this now uh makes it very
very problematic because it also gives
the C6 Square to the White Knight and
that's a problem either the Knight
remains on C6 forever or you have to
capture it and then give Magnus um a
pass Pawn already on C6 so there's a uh
there's really no good way to handle
this E5 is still not possible as the
king is on G8 so Bishop to C8 was played
and uh again if you play King to h8 it
doesn't really matter Knight to C6 goes
after the rook and if you move the Rook
you lose the bishop so you have to
capture here and giving white this past
Pawn is just too much for example Pawn
E5 Pawn to C7 Rook C8 and Bishop to A6
uh game over so after Pawn to B5 Bishop
to C8 was played by Gregory but now
Knight to C6 and already you can feel
the power of this Knight and of course
Magnus knows that none of this would be
possible without that pawn to be for
Pawn push uh Rook to D6 and now Rook to
C7 uh we have Bishop to D7 now Rook to
A1 preparing to double up Rooks on the
seventh rank of course we all know what
Rooks on the seventh rank are called
they are called pigs as they gobble up
everything uh Bishop to f8 and now Rook
a to A7 and now the the the pigs or the
the Hogs of War are simply Unstoppable
you have to play Bishop captures on C6 B
captures Magnus now gets a beautiful
pass C Pawn already on C6 Rook to D1
check King to G2 and now Rook to C1
trying to put the Rook behind the pass
Pawn H but now Rook to A4 Magnus plans
on keeping the bishop here uh sort of to
be able to move the rook and Advance the
pass Pawn but now Gregory finds a very
tricky Pawn to B5 move and okay Bishop
captures and now he throws in Rook to C5
now the bishop will not be able to uh
pose in between the the rook and the
pass Pawn still Bishop to C4 keeps
control of this diagonal and now Bishop
to D6 attacking Magnus is Rook on C7
Rook to
B7 uh and now uh King to h8 King to f8
also possible but it doesn't matter
objectively Magnus is already winning
here now it's only a matter of Will he
win this now finally the unpinning
happens uh the UN the famous unpinning
of the King on G8 uh but now Bishop
captures on E6 and uh you know it took
the king this long to unpin but now
Bishop just captures point is that if
you capture of course Rook to A8 will be
Checkmate after you give up a few pieces
so uh that cannot be played Rook to E7
Gregory offers a rook trade but Magnus
happily accepts captures captures Rook
to A8 with check King to G7 and now not
Rook to G8 check although it looks very
nice Rook to A7 is better just putting
pressure on the bishop and the problem
is if you defend the bishop C7 just wins
as the uh C8 square is defended By the
Light Square Bishop on E6 so after Rook
A7 Gregory decided to give up the bishop
and maybe try to hold on but uh you know
that's easier said than then done Rook
captures an E7 check King f8 and Rook to
F7 check and he was in this position un
move 44 that gregori kaido resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh so the point is that if you
go King to E8 uh okay you don't want to
go under the mask of the bishop but if
you go here then simply a very nice Rook
trade Bishop D7 check forces a rook
trade and you up a full bishop and uh
the other thing you could try is of
course go under the mask of the bishop
but now you will just play Rook captures
an F6 with check to keep your Bishop
defended and after King G7 you will
repeat King uh Rook F7 check King to h8
and now just move the bishop and you're
up a full pce doesn't really matter you
will consolidate here with something
like this or even King F3 and you're up
a full Bishop end up a pawn of course
completely winning if if anyone would
like me to create a tutorial on how to
win end games where you are up a full
piece I can also do that I mean I
believe it that kind of a tutorial also
has its worth uh so yeah very nicely
done by by mag Magus but you know uh at
64 years of age very nicely done by by
Gregory Kido as well taking down
magnus's prodig Yan F forest in the
previous game and now holding his own
against Magnus basically up until the
the very end um uh you
know a move precise a couple of moves
ago would have probably given him a draw
but of course you know you you have to
find that kind of a move against Magnus
every move uh and then you will maybe
get a draw but but if not then you you
will lose or sometimes you win like
kakan defeated him uh two rounds ago uh
so yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it uh sorry about two videos in
two games in one video but I thought it
would be very nice as I decided to show
both of kaidanov games uh so I hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank your
mom's modern mate tuer Beckman Eddie
Indus bullet chest thriller.com and
chatmate for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching uh and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and also everything else
that's happening in the Chess World Plus
uh the the final round of course will be
covered of this wonderful event if you
have any other games that you would like
to see from the pen ultimate round of
cutter Masters uh do use hash suggestion
and I will go over it and remember
tomorrow we have um a live stream with
ala fua uh with with the improve app ala
will be holding a simultaneous
exhibition against 20 of our uh
improvers well he will be taking them on
and try to of course defeat all of them
so if you are interested in that tune in
in the live stream it will start maybe
6:30 p.m. Central European Time or maybe
maybe six uh basically uh it will take
first we will talk about um what we are
doing for for like half an hour and then
ala will join us and he will take on the
you know the full Squad of of the
improve improvers and try to defeat all
of them uh and you know if you guys have
some questions for ala I will also I I
will try to annoy ala as much as
possible you know so he messes up but
chances are he he will not so yeah once
again hope you enjoyed that um uh and
yeah thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day